First we're going to look at the number of steps, the step complexity.
And that should be the same as reduction
since all are running as a whole bunch of parallel reductions.
The reductions all have different sizes.
So to get the overall step complexity, we need to look at the largest reduction,
which is a reduction at the end here of all n elements.
So the number of steps to reduce n elements
and thus the number of steps to perform this entire computation is O(log n).
To compute the total amount of work, we notice that we're going to have n reductions to perform.
The 1st reduction requires 0 additions,
the 2nd reduction requires a single addition,
the 3rd reduction requires 2 additions and, in general, the nth output will require n - 1 additions.
And so what we're going to have to do is sum up that whole series, 0 + 1 + 2 on to n - 1.
And if we do add up that series, we're going to find that the result is roughly n^2 /2 additions.
So the overall amount of work is proportional to the square of the number of elements.
We would say that the number of additions overall is O(n^).
So while we like having a smaller number of steps than the serial version--
remember that took O(n) steps--
this quadratic work complexity makes this formulation of scan ridiculously inefficient.
So what we're going to do next is look at 2 other algorithms that have a more reasonable cost.